on august 24
2020 as covid19 cases were spiking
across the state
the university of illinois welcomed
students back to campus at
urbana-champaign for the fall semester
the decision was informed by months of
planning and research
according to an epidemiological model
developed by university professors
there could be a relatively safe way to
open campus for in-person classes
you're doing 10 000 to 15 000 tests a
day
we're testing everybody on our campus at
illinois urbana champaign
twice a week results can be accessed on
an app
things didn't go according to plan on
september 1st just a week after students
returned to campus
there was an outbreak two weeks in the
university of illinois reported more
than 700 cases which is more than they
expected for the semester
and the university of illinois wasn't
alone at this point we should not be
surprised
that the model got it wrong it sounds
like i'm saying i don't really trust the
experts
because i don't why does it seem like
covet 19 models are getting it so
wrong in reality there's a lot more
going on here
in order to understand how models can be
useful we first have to understand how
they're built
what they can and can't tell us and how
all of this
often gets lost in translation
epidemiology
is not rocket science it's harder
when scientists build an epidemiological
model what they're really doing is
writing down a recipe
for how they think the reality of an
epidemic unfolds
and adding math so that they can project
that reality into different possible
futures
typically in a model what you'll do is
first write down
what we call the variables these are the
things that are changing over time
and then in the next steps what you're
going to write down is just how those
different variables
interact and then what you hope to do is
take
some observations about the real world
and help to
parameterize your model how fast does
the disease spread from one person to
another
how many contacts does a typical person
of some
age have with people of other ages
scientists use two main approaches to
building models of covid19
agent-based and compartmental models
most models are a combination of both
with an agent-based model our goal is to
think about individual agents
in this case people and we give them
certain rules or certain behaviors
and then can simulate forward based on
those behaviors how they interact
and in the case of covet how they spread
disease and how their behaviors might
change
because of the disease around them but
agent-based models don't easily scale to
very
large populations they can also require
a prohibitive amount of computational
resources to run
so for a broader perspective scientists
also use compartmental models
or seir models everyone in the
population
falls into one of these categories s
for susceptible to the disease e for
exposed
i for infectious and r for recovered or
removed
you can think about these compartments
as different stages of the disease
modelers use differential equations to
simulate how people move from one stage
to the next
based on data like infection rate
hospitalization rate
and fatality rate scientists can use
approaches like compartmental and
agent-based models to approximate
reality
but reality is a complicated and
unpredictable place
rife with uncertainty first off we all
go in assuming we're going to be wrong
we understand that there is no way to
get it
right there is no such thing as a model
that will
exactly represent the world or can
possibly
capture every one of the dynamics in the
real world
the prediction is very sensitive to data
to how good data is
data is dispersed is incomplete
and is not taken with
one uniform protocol everywhere when you
don't have good data
you cannot have good predictions small
differences in the parameter are
amplified as the dynamics of the system
progresses
so this is very similar to the butterfly
effect
a slightly different initial condition
leads to a very different
outcome this exponential sensitivity
causes differences to amplify
exponentially fast so you have a
spreading cone
of possible trajectories of your future
but there's an even deeper source of
uncertainty that lurks in every model
that source is us
when we look at human behavior and human
dynamics there's a huge amount of
uncertainty there
as you can imagine our daily mobility
patterns our daily contact patterns
are so out of the norm we've been
scrambling
to find data to get
insight into how people are behaving
during covet and how that behavior is
changing on
you know a weekly basis in the absence
of data on relevant human behaviors
modelers have to make assumptions a
small error or a missed assumption can
have profound consequences on the
model's outcome
and even correct assumptions can change
over time
causing the model to veer way off course
from its original projections
this is why nobody can predict the
future
not even modelers models
fundamentally depend on what are the
assumptions that you make
we made assumptions that people would be
partying we estimated
how much that would be going on
what we didn't take into account is we
didn't expect that people would be
non-compliant
in other words if you're told to isolate
we assume that people would actually
do that and that assumption was one of
the most
erroneous ones that we made
[Music]
as a modeler you have to try to focus on
one of the important things
and they may not be the things that you
would spend most of your time
on as a scientist writing paper for
publication but if you're doing that but
meanwhile
you've left out the fact that a third of
the people in your population
don't even believe that you should be
even trying to
mitigate coverage that's a far more
important
source of error the statistician george
e p
box once famously said all models are
wrong
but some are useful instead of
predictions
something modelers can offer us is
projections
these are glimpses into a range of
possible futures that we have the power
to change
the best early models are the ones that
are wrong
precisely because we react to them and
make them wrong so
when we see projections about what could
happen were we to do nothing at all
the fact that those projections are
invariably wrong
is fantastic because that means we
actually respond to the model's
predictions and
prove them wrong but even when a model
does the job it's supposed to do
there's a risk that it could be
misunderstood when the worst case
scenario
doesn't come to pass how do we
communicate
when we can't predict the future but we
can provide scenario predictions right
so
and this this is a real challenge for um
for scientists for modelers but it's
also a really important responsibility
we have
early in the pandemic one of the very
first requests we received from
policymakers trying to understand what
the threat was and trying to
figure out what the right path forward
was was a request from the white house
coronavirus
task force what do your models say about
how many people are going to die from
coveted 19 in 2020
we responded and said you know we don't
have a crystal ball it depends on the
policies it depends on people's behavior
so we we can't give you a forecast but
we can make some projections
under a number of different scenarios
for example we can make projections
under the assumption
that we do not do anything to slow the
spread of this virus
or we'll consider sort of the opposite
extreme we'll assume that we're staying
strict for the foreseeable future
and then let's consider something in
between where we're sort of on a roller
coaster of trying to contain this virus
and the forecasts under those scenarios
look very different there's been a lot
of what they call
modeling in the science of infectious
diseases that's been done
that is now being understood to have
been really wrong
there's a lot of misunderstanding about
the application of models
but i'd love to see the public take away
from our modeling for covin
is that this is one tool in the toolkit
it's really important for us all to
understand how the tools get used
nobody knew anything about
epidemiological modeling
12 months ago all of a sudden we're
seeing the results of modeling on the
nightly news
and i find it fascinating and and and
really
pretty awe inspiring that there's this
huge uptick in
really scientific awareness and
awareness of what mathematical modeling
even
is and i think a new appreciation for
the fact that
it's out there so these pandemics will
come again we are
a relationship with nature that favors
that the pathogens jump from one species
to another
so for the future what i envision is
something similar to what
we currently do with weather forecasts
we have full institutions we have a
surveying systems with many
weather stations all over our
territories that inform us of the
current conditions everywhere
and this is fed into models that
continuously update their forecasts why
don't we have that for pandemics
this is not a matter of a single country
we have to be together
in this so when we face a new uh
challenge and they will come then we are
ready just to
plug in the new data that instantly
arrives right and say something about
how this can spread
[Music]
[Music]
you